it's easy being watched 24 hours a day
it's easy committing crimes under their
eyes dealing with stone-cold killers
people say this is easy what's easy
about it you know what's easy is sitting
behind a desk all day for eight hours
and punching numbers into a computer
that's what's easy you took the easy way
out my name is Mike Silverman and I used
to be part of the Winter Hill Gang and
as we're standing here and the Winter
Hill neighborhood it's brought back many
memories
it was a huge close-knit family of
mafioso but they happen to be Irish
my dad's house in the cellar I had a
bookmaking operation down there and when
I started out I thought I was gonna be
like the sixth family you know what I
mean I thought I was gonna be the big
thing and you know I had with some drug
dealing going on a lot of mobsters live
score to score and when we made those
big scores it was like party time we
would rent out hotel rooms like a whole
floor and we would just have parties for
like a week and we were just living it
up it's no different than I guess a drug
addiction you're addicted to the power
you're addicted to doing whatever the
hell you want
it sounds good to say hey I won't earn
in your territory or I won't do anything
it sounds great but can you really keep
that promise I couldn't keep it in
Southie I mean I got lured there to just
do a deal most of my income came from
the drug business mostly marijuana I
mean I had I had a supply coming from
New Mexico to Arizona and all the way
yeast I mean it was just a pipeline it
was a lot of marijuana
anyways I put the duffel bag full of
marijuana in the trunk along with a gun
and we took off for the trip when I
pulled up I popped the trunk all of a
sudden BAM he cracked me in the side of
the head with a gun as he pushed me into
the room I looked up but I noticed that
it was all lined in plastic and my hot
song I could feel someone grabbed my
hair and pull my head up and when I
looked up there he was
it was James Whitey Bulger the eyes of
the Irish devil himself at this point I
know I'm dead there's nothing I can say
nothing I can do I walked into it
word on the street was if you called him
whitey he would cut your balls off so I
said your Jim Bulger and he gave me a
wry smile like that's right he said now
get yourself together
if you ever show you a face in Southie
again you're a dead man and I didn't
care that it was insulting you know
that's where the money was I went and I
did it unfortunately I learned my lesson
this is what it's like being a mobster
you fend for yourself and you're
constantly starting over
as far as being out of the mob I don't
think you're ever out you know you're
really not supposed to get out per se
because as they say you you come in and
then you go out in a box and that that's
the only way you leave I'm starting over
right in my fourth book you know so I
would probably have to be insane to keep
doing the same things that I did over
and over again right inside of me will
always be that guy that did the things
that I did I pledged myself to that
organization I guess I'll leave it at
that